pratique à l'époque c'était quand même
très original en france de créer
tellement aimer la science fiction en
france en tant qu'auteur oui alors
d'abord les gens méprisent rsa les
journalistes râlent les les professeurs
avec détestais ça et est évidemment les
parents n'avaient jamais lu un bouquin
de science fiction et alors que c'était
une lecture vraiment extraordinaire je
parle des romans l'asie move deux
filles a indiqué etc c'était des romans
magnifique dans les années 50 et nous on
savait que c'était formidable mais on a
tout simplement
transposer ça sur papier ça ça se
faisait pas et quand christian et moi on
a proposé à goscinny qui dirigeait
pilote qui dirige à pyla qu'on est à la
grande époque de 2 après mon retour des
états unis où j'avais travaillé avec
christain qui était prof d'université en
utah parce que lui il avait de la charge
de famille et donc qu'il fallait qu'ils
fassent des choses sérieuses et on a dit
on pourrait faire une petite histoire de
30 pages dans le journal de pages par
semaine surtout pas un album c'était
parfait pour faire 30 pages cependant à
des albums mais sait aussi que ça on ne
savait même pas ce qu'on pouvait faire
on nous a donné vraiment là le la grande
qualité de ce directeur de journal
n'était pas de dire nos lecteurs veulent
ceux ci et là vous avez essayé envie
d'essayer allez-y allez-y l'essai
[Musique]